the thought of someone Junior having
empathy for someone senior is like one
of the most foreign Concepts in the
world and I think it's one of the most
important requirements for the junior
person's own happiness it seems so
counterintuitive hey Junior person you
want to be happy deploy empathy for your
manager or your manager's manager or
your Leader's leader and you'll be
happier that sounds in outer space
because there's entitlement that comes
with being Junior you're supposed to do
it for me leader but you don't even
understand what the leader is going
through I think that lack of compassion
and empathy really hurts people people
understand it going down like people
don't understand it looking up and
that's a theme to definitely talk about
it'll help people make them happier